hello i'm louise hughes the product
manager for life science at oxford
instruments nano analysis
and i would like to thank you for
watching my tech talk on multi-color
biological electron microscopy
with eds
electron microscopy has been used for
decades in biological research
primarily because of its ability to
provide high resolution images of
specimens
however this does come with some
restraints and these revolve around the
sample preparation
often involving some form of fixation
and then
if not using cryo-electron microscopy
dehydration of the sample
contrast is often added in the form of
heavy metal stains
and for tm the samples are usually
embedded and resin
and sectioned for sem they would be
dried and coated
the sample you can see on the screen is
the planed
face of a resin embedded hydroxyapatite
bone implant in the process of
degradation
and it's been imaged using an sem
it was hoped that by using heavy metal
staining on the sample
there would be enough of a contrast
difference to see cellular material
but apart from one distinct cell in the
center
it is actually quite challenging to
differentiate between the implant and
the tissue
and this is because of the grayscale
nature of
imaging samples with sem and tm
instead we can use a technique that has
been gaining a lot of interest over the
past few years
and that is multi-color electron
microscopy
combining the electron images with
additional signals
generated as a result of exposing a
biological sample
to an electron beam
the image shown here is now a much more
colorful image and you can
clearly see some distinct features
including the green cellular material
that is scattered throughout the lacunae
within the implant
and this indicates how multi-color
electron microscopy
can be a really powerful imaging tool
in the example shown here we've used a
technique called energy dispersive x-ray
spectrometry
also known as eds or edx
eds detects and measures the energy of
x-rays emitted from the sample
and i'll go into a little bit more
detail about this in a minute
the energy of the x-ray indicates the
element
it originates from thus providing
information about the composition of the
sample
and this also results in striking images
such as this one
which massively aids interpretation of
the images produced
these diagrams help to explain a little
bit about what's going on
when the electron beam interacts with a
sample
on the left you can see the beam
interacting with a specimen
and a range of different signals being
emitted from different depths within the
sample
these include secondary electrons and
back scattered electrons
that are commonly used for imaging it
also includes
characteristic x-rays and these are the
ones we detect
using eds and continuum or background
x-rays
as well as a variety of other
fluorescence signals
on the right hand side you can see a
schematic of an atom
and some of the interactions that occur
when the main beam electrons interact
with atoms within the sample
several things can happen the electrons
can be transmitted
and these are the ones detected in tm or
they can be scattered
and the scattered electrons create
contrast
the diagram also indicates where we have
elastic
and inelastic scattering of electrons
elastically scattered electrons occur
when main beam electrons are slowed down
and lose energy as a result of passing
close to the atomic nucleus
and this released energy is in the form
of background or continuum x-rays
main beam electrons can also transfer
energy to an electron
within one of the shells surrounding the
atomic nucleus and this results in the
production and emission of a secondary
electron
the loss of this electron from one of
the inner shells
results in the ionization of the atom
and creates an unstable state
and this stability is regained when an
electron from an
outer shell fills that inner shell
vacancy
and it does this by releasing the energy
in the form of an x-ray photon
these x-ray photons are known as
characteristic x-rays
because measuring the energy of the
x-ray indicates
the type of atom that it originated from
so allows us to identify the elements
within a sample
and this is what we try to do with eds
an example image of an eds detector is
shown here on the left
and you can see this now to the detector
lying alongside the pole piece
of a scanning electron microscope we
also have tem
detectors which aren't shown here this
is where we collect the x-rays emitted
from the sample
and these are detected using a silicon
drift detector
which converts them into an electronic
signal
this is then sent to a processor which
measures the electronic signal and
calculates the energy of the x-rays
our aztec software displays the spectrum
of x-rays
and automatically identifies and
deconvolutes the data
and removes background this is a fast
process
and is performed as the electron beam is
scanning across a sample
storing a spectrum for each position of
the electron beam
and this can then be converted into a
map of the elements within the sample
as shown in the image on the right
here is a closer look at a spectrum
generated from the sample
shown in the electron image at the top
left of the slide
featuring macrophages grown on a plastic
coverslip
and the things i want you to pay
attention to here is that along the
bottom
we have our x-ray energy and where we
have our peaks
that's where we've accumulated many
x-ray counts
at that energy so the peaks
indicate x-ray intensity
and this allows us to generate
quantitative data
about how much of each element is within
our sample
so we can convert this information into
maps
and have displays representing the
distribution
of elements across the sample and here's
an example
where we've got several different maps
and this is a low mag image of the
example i showed you at the start of
this presentation
you can see in the maps you get relative
different intensities
of signal across the area being scanned
these are individual maps so each map
shows the distribution
of an individual element
and these images can be combined with
the electron data
to produce a multi-layered map as you
can see here
and each of these images contains
quantitative values
for each element at each pixel position
so if you want to revisit your data at
any point
and obtain quantitative values it is
possible to do that within our software
eds can thus provide you with a range of
information about your specimen
it can identify what elements are
present within your sample
can measure how much of each element is
present and
display them in a proportional basis
and also indicate where each element is
located within your sample
by producing eds maps
what does this mean for biological
research well i'm going to spend the
next
few minutes just giving you a few
different examples
of how eds can contribute to our
understanding of biological specimens
eds can be used to map the distribution
of and measure endogenous
elements these are elements that are
naturally found within biological
tissue and this can be done either to
directly
measure those elements or and in the
vast majority of cases
to compare changes in elements between
samples for example if you've
added a treatment or looking at
different time points within your sample
it could also be used to identify areas
where you have an
enhancement of any particular one
element for example
calcium and here we have an example of
an unstained plant cell and this was
imaged in a tem
and you can clearly see in the
multi-layer map how we've got
a really nice distribution of elements
across the cell itself you can
see the nucleus in the middle of the
image
and i've got two individual maps one
showing the phosphorus and one showing
calcium
and by selecting regions within my maps
i can then produce
quantitative values of the weight
percentage
of elements in those regions and in the
chart i've just
shown you the weight percentage of
phosphorus and calcium
in these three regions that i've
selected
in this way we can measure and compare
within the same
sample but also between samples imaged
under the same type of conditions
here is another example and this is
again
plant cells these are stained with
osmium and zinc as you can see in the
maps
and i wanted to show you this as it's an
example of where you can find
specific regions of interest in this
instance
a concentration of iron in the
chloroplast
which is a relatively rare occurrence
but can quite clearly be identified
using eds in this example
it is also possible to identify and
measure exogenous elements and these can
be things
that are found in biological tissue but
have an
origin outside of it and this can be
things like
pollutants heavy metal contamination
nanoparticles surgical implants a
variety of different
types and here we have an example of
macrophages
that have been exposed to cobalt
nanoparticles
and eds has been used here to identify
the cobalt
nanoparticles as being separate from
some of the other regions of the tissue
that have an equally bright back
scattered electron signal
and actually compose of sodium
and silicon
here we have a second example and this
shows
particles from air pollution deposited
onto the surface of a leaf
and these leaves were collected by rob
kessler one of our collaborators
you can see how eds can easily be used
to identify the composition
of these pollutant particles on the leaf
surface
as mentioned earlier on in the
presentation staining
is a very big part of electron
microscopy
and necessary in order to be able to
localize specific areas and visualize
the sample
and here we have a couple of examples
where we're using
eds to analyze the distribution of a
selective stain in the sample so on the
left hand side
we have images of venus's fly trap and
this has been
stained using zinc iodide osmium
and you can see that there's a
variability
in the ratio between zinc and osmium in
different regions across the sample
and this can be quite informative as to
the contents of different cells and
organelles
on the right hand side there's a
reference to a publication
where they've used eds to identify
different
types of immunolabel which can be used
to
localize proteins within cells and you
can see here
that the electron contrast image
means you just get black dots for the
label but if you turn on the eds
you can identify the different
components of the labels
in this case cadmium dots and gold
immunolabels
cds can be used not only to look at
components naturally within the cells or
exogenous components that have been
introduced but also
used to help you analyze the labels and
stains you've applied to the
sample there may be some samples where
you've not been able to add additional
contrast
for example samples used for
immunolabeling
and cryo em samples and in those
situations it can be really difficult to
analyze cell
ultrastructure here we have an example
where we have an unstained cell such as
that
that would usually be produced for
immune labeling
and you can see the difference between
the stained cell and the unstained cell
but as soon as we turn on the eds using
the element maps we are actually able to
pick up a lot of these
thin thylakoid membranes that are
indicated by the orange arrows
in the chloroplast here so in this
instance we're able to use
eds to image the ultrastructure of the
sample instead of using
electron contrast
here we're actually looking at a cryo
sample and we're able to use eds to
identify
the line of cells here in this wheat
seed which could otherwise be quite
difficult to identify
so i hope i've been able to show you a
few different examples of how eds
can address biological samples
facilitate
identification of composition and also
help
with imaging your sample and this is
where
the multi-color electron microscopy
really comes into its own
oxford instruments have a range of
different detectors that
are optimized in such a way that they
make it ideal for looking at life
science samples
and you can see them here the ultim 170
is our largest
area detector and i'll show you in a
minute why that's quite important
the ultimix stream is a windowless
detector
which means it doesn't have a window
between the environment of the
microscope chamber
and the silicon drift detector so
more of the light element x-rays can
actually get through to hit the detector
and this can be quite important for life
science samples
the ultimax tle is our tem
equivalent of the ultim extreme
for the reason that large area detectors
are so important
is it increases our speed and it
increases the count rate
so if you compare here the images
generated
between a traditional 10 millimeter
square detector
and the ultra max large area detectors
you can see in the bottom of the range
of images
how much area and information from a
sample we can obtain in the same amount
of time
so we're imaging the sample for less
time and collecting a lot more of the
x-rays emitted from the sample
and this makes a really big difference
for the time it takes to analyze your
sample
you can see a cutaway diagram showing a
conventional eds detector design
and you can see that it has a window
between
the crystal and the exterior of the
detector
and this is in order to protect the
crystal
from the environment so we've been able
to change this design and actually
remove that window
and this can be important because the
window can absorb
low energy x-rays emitted from the
sample and low energy x-rays are often
emitted from light elements
of which most biological samples are
composed
and here we have a comparison between
a standard eds detector like the alter
max 170
and the ultimix stream detector which is
our windowless detector
and you can see by redesigning the end
of the detector
and removing the window we've been able
to reduce
the distance from which the detector is
from the sample
and this is quite important because it
also means we can reduce the working
distance
and improve the resolution of our images
doing so
i've already mentioned that removing the
window improves the detection of light
elements
and you can see this quite clearly in
this
image comparison on the right hand side
where we've got the ultimax 120 and the
ultim extreme now this is imaged at 6 kv
and you can quite clearly see in the eds
maps
how we get a lot stronger signal in
particular from the yellow component
which is nitrogen
and nitrogen is very easily absorbed by
the window
of standard eds detectors but with the
ultim extreme we're able to
actually detect and measure the nitrogen
in the sample
which is particularly important for
biological
specimens
so to summarize the ultimate extreme
detector
has excellent light element detection
ideal for low energy x-rays and looking
at the endogenous elements in biological
samples
and because it can detect low energy
x-rays
it also means that it can operate
under low kv conditions in an scm
which improves the image resolution it
can improve sample
stability and reduce damage to being
sensitive specimens
like most biological samples are it also
has maximized the count rate of x-rays
it can
receive by having a large area detector
which means you can image samples for
less time
and we've optimized electronics in the
system so that
it's much faster but also produces a lot
less noise
thus optimizing the difference between
the peaks and the background in the
spectrum
and facilitating identification
and our ultim tle detector is the tem
equivalent which is a windowless
detector in a temp
so i hope from this you're able to take
away some understanding of what
multicolor electron microscopy using eds
is
and how it can benefit your research
whether you're looking at
endogenous elements exogenous elements
stains labels or just trying to generate
more contrast and identify specific
regions
within your sample and i finished with a
bit of summary about our detectors
but specifically the ultimate extreme
which is optimized for biological
research
in an sem setting thank you very much
for your attention
please take a look at our website if you
want more information
or speak to us on our exhibition booth
thank you very much